hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to destiny rebellion
now I figured out what I needed to do
but I didn't get it on camera so I need
to do it again so that you guys can see
what I needed to do boom that's what I
needed to do so now I'm gonna go in here
and I'm gonna try to find my way into
the keycard that I need which I'm
assuming that this is gonna bring me
right around back though beside the
behind there I can't talk I can't talk
at all it's gonna bring me back around
behind that door that was apparently
locked and now I'm gonna be able to go
around get the security card go out the
way I came and then be done with the
thing what is that okay
so I kind of forgot my light oh I'm
gonna go number level all right so I
file it oh well this is pleasant I
wonder about sort of nightmares await me
here nice naked people nice dead people
nice creepy person these are all lovely
paintings okay sorry I apologize I
didn't know you were in there I am so
sorry I didn't mean to bother you what
was he doing just standing there there's
no point to that I picked up a mobile
phone why one of three hidden secret
bonus items they're a mobile phone the
cigarette and seed of darkness can I
find them all why do I need to what
benefit what possible benefit would that
do me oh that is much better oh that's
much better so the next thing I need to
find is the cigarette why is he in -
okay maybe the claw could help it maybe
damn [ __ ] get out the way get out the
way [ __ ] get out the way forgive me you
are forgiven I don't even know what you
did you could have murdered like ten
thousand baby seals and I forgive you
because I'm cool like that where's their
green blood on the wall I am so sorry
that's okay let me just slowly caress
your face with my claw it's okay it's
alright I forgive you oh did that
actually do anything what am i doing
besides just stabbing into his face but
we need a phone no just gonna keep
stabbing Amir hope no one comes along
and sees me the monster that I am what
is it what is that doing what is that
replenishing myself I'm eating him I'm a
monster and I replenishing myself with
that
that's so weird and cool good thinking
that's all - med kits in the hospital
there we go that is much more pleasant
Oh your dark why was it light out there
but dark in here nice paintings of
weirdos good for you
the monsoon as I see me what monster oh
that one yeah I'm gonna get you the hell
just happened I don't know why okay oh
that was the monster that was in here
before good I murdered him I'm so happy
that I did that are those batteries and
flashlights can I get those somehow I
bet I can I bet I can bug the crap out
of this thing come on line break I need
you for stuff and things heat you come
on baby I need you and your Flash lady
goodness hello pig mask and lots of
tinderboxes that looks suspiciously like
laters one use sliders
oh how incredibly awesome so I guess
there's no other point to any of that
there must have been something in this
room that I needed otherwise why would
he have been guarding it and why would I
have needed to kill the monster in the
first place these are all questions that
are totally logical
but then again I'm playing a custom
story that may not actually be logical
well then I just need to continue on why
is it dark in here I let this place up
dead dead dead dead dead dead dead dead
all dead dead dead I'm dropping iron oh
they do need humans to live what okay
that's an explanation that is the first
time I've asked a question in one of
these custom stories and they want some
on this bench
you want some black very good I
apologize you rival monster douche I'm
just gonna go over here now
I'm gonna go away circle back a move
that guy is buff okay so it's dark and
he does not see me he does not know that
I am going to ambush the piss out of him
so I'm gonna ambush the blood out of him
oh come on unforgivable doctors preserve
humanity artificially enhanced physical
strength afraid they're gonna test their
adventures on humans what are you
talking about are they trying to
physically enhance humans so that they
can get stronger humans and then
hopefully get more food out of the
humans by a woman is that a woman is
that a woman that the experimentation
went wrong hello human where'd you go
mister who me man hello did you go where
did he go ah that is hardly fair I was
gonna kill him I was gonna stab him up
though I'm just gonna back away from
this room slowly close the door and let
you finish your business in there
whatever the hell it may have been some
sort of BDSM torn you hey if you hear
any car what did I do
I took the keycard I took the curity
card okay I'll just be on my way
okay no I shouldn't got in there that
door was closed for a reason private
things were happening that guy's bum bum
thank you hello hmm oh hi what are you
why are you clothed it's it's odd that
the weird thing is that they're wearing
clothes whereas before they were not oh
this is ha ha ha
aren't you a squiggly man Willy Willy
Willy Doolittle do it
hello hi bye bye room of hanging people
by burning Guy or burning man I should
say but that's probably like trademark
do something hello what's that nothing
god there's a whole lot of interesting
stuff
Oh big spinning blades of doom that's
good we are all doomed my colleague who
escaped the hospital through the
basement of semia mentions mint and we
are doomed
I cannot say words today what in the
world could be behind that door
I see wait a minute I thought this was
what was behind that door there's a nice
tasty juicy tours oh these blades aren't
really doing a lot of
the walls let alone their ability to cut
seems to be hindered a bit hello did you
try to escape your fate too bad was the
point of all this there's a dead guy
another one I may say hi you're new are
you humans are you humming humans
is this your focal box I'm sorry I
apologize where are you coming from
where are you where are you where is he
huh where is he what does go down I'm
not dying
that is me dying why am i dying sorry I
apologize for everything
I'm so sorry I'll just be on my way The
Doors stuck and made of unbreakable
power glass let me just hit it with my
power claw oh there you are
I'm sorry Wow death is the final unknown
is that a quote from Captain Picard on
the Star Trek's okay oh I'm over here
now do I still I didn't get anything
there was no point being here they was
at lead
I thought I saw something in there I
guess those are scientists but why are
there still humans that are scientists
okay so I got to be careful what is that
human anatomy first public autopsy huh
yes that was in that trailer for
what's-his-face Adam Jansen the guy who
did the thing okay the thingy
human civilization does not end with
death of all humans it ends with giving
up the humanity but what exactly is
manatee good question nice philosophical
crap wait a minute this is the door
behind the door isn't it it is the door
behind the door wait a minute maybe
that's the door behind the lasers they
said something about the door behind the
lasers but I don't know which one was
which wait a minute what weren't you out
here wait a minute something don't smell
right maybe it's all the death and blood
and poison gas but some don't smell
right here and I'm gonna get to the
bottom of it unless it's bottom is on
its top and then I'm gonna get to the
top of it once it's on its side then I'm
gonna get to the vertical of it now my
brain hurts oh it's dark level
transition okay there we go
well that's some rather interesting
housing decoration stuff thing oh wait a
minute I know this place this is Rob
from this Ralph's house Ralph Ralph not
raw from Eddie and Eddie but no wait no
is it yeah it is
what the hell is going on here good god
don't do that to me I was weird
this place has probably been
hermetically sealed for centuries I
don't think you know what hermetically
sealed means
okay well the rods are still here but
all six this is the time machine when it
is properly charged the only thing to
make it work is pull the lever
destination date is July 2nd 1902
if I succeed this letter and the whole
time machine should disappear because I
have changed my past and I have never
built this if anybody reads this note it
means
I failed cuz you went into the future
you dingus I don't even know how I got
here
why am I here I'm a monster hello I'm
gonna go back in time now kill the
Romans I'm gonna kill Homans maybe it's
like a time loop like I am the cause and
the result of this plague that caused
the monsters no that's almost becoming a
cliche no that's Starly Doctor Who crap
in there Oh dad is an ice castle where
am I
something must be wrong am I wrong what
is this place is not 1902 it's not even
Planet Earth okay I think so but what
exactly is this place how are you my
name is Lazar you're human aren't you
are you gonna be my friend are you going
to kill me no I used the time machine so
I could see hoomans not to kill them I
came from 2091 you used my time machine
in the future I did not expect that
could happen damn it now I have to find
a way out of here
I need technology I think I could find
it inside that giant castle but the
castle gate is locked for golden keys
are needed to open it Lazar you said
loves are you said yes so are we going
to search for the keys I don't trust you
if you want to help me try to find some
golden eagle keys I'm going to search on
my own the strange new world is not
going to stop me okay yeah I wouldn't
trust him either he's got the face of
someone who's just a little bit wonky
so much off the top if you know what I
mean so am I wrong
yes I am so now I need to find a weird
alien cigarette and while he's gonna
find some alien pees of some sort why
would an alien planet even have a golden
eagle that's what I want to know about
and I only know if graves okay so all
I'm super fast now whoa what did I do
excuse me
pardon dear sir sipper by using advanced
sealing patterns these seals can
teleport the user to different places
there's no risk in using this a
consortin the travel time and distance
anyway use it carefully so I can port to
the different there's like four
different zones here the way of Darkness
God that is cool can we just take a
second to appreciate how much work was
put into this because it's a lot holy
crap that is cool anyway so I'm all that
time for this part but I'm gonna
continue on very shortly so thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always
[Music]
[Music]
developer planned it this way there's
Holi